It was Christmas Day, 1995.
My brother Rich and I, we're up early,
we're excited, it's Christmas.
He rushed into my room
and in there my father had left
his IBM ThinkPad and a note.
"This is so you don't wake up
your mother and me early.
Merry Christmas."
Next to it was a present.
It was a video game,
a football game, FIFA '96.
We tore it open,
put it into that laptop
and we huddled around
and played the match to end all matches.
We played so many more matches after that,
but neither of us became
professional footballers.
Richard?
He's a lawyer.
Me, I work with data
to go and help organizations
get that competitive edge and win.
Back in '95, that game
was just a video game.
Nothing more.
Little did we know
that in the years to come
you’d be able to compete
in massive online competitions.
More importantly, you’d be able
to go and connect with people
around the world
that you've never met before
and have a shared experience.
And that's exactly what is happening.
The lines between the physical
and the digital world are blurring.
And we're entering into a new world
where we can start to dream bigger.
A far cry from the '90s,
video gaming has overtaken music
as the most important
aspect of youth culture.
I see this with my children.
They're much more likely
to go and watch the latest video
of someone playing Minecraft or Roblox
than look up what the UK
latest number one single is.
And this has led to a shift
in how we consume entertainment.
We are no longer consumers of it.
We are now being shared participants
in an online experience.
I myself love gaming.
Not particularly good at it,
but I love it.
And I love the Formula 1 game.
And that’s because I love real-world
Formula 1 racing.
I'm going to show you a clip why.
So this is Lando Norris,
one of McLaren’s Formula 1 drivers.
Multiple podium wins last year
driving the MCL35M --
oh, MCL36, sorry --
the car for this year
in pre-season testing.
Let's have a look at this.
(Car engine revving)
Isn't the noise of one of those
just incredible?
But the atmosphere, the drama,
the suspense of going
to one of these races
and watching those cars
go around, over 200 miles an hour,
it's electric.
But few of us will ever get
to sit in one of those cars,
let alone be one of those
drivers on the grid.
And that’s because in Formula 1,
there are only 20 professional drivers.
There are ten teams
with two drivers per team.
It's perhaps the most inaccessible
sport in the world.
Suffice to say, there are going to be
so many people with dreams,
talent and ambition to get there
who will never be able to make it.
I'm going to introduce you
to someone called Rudy.
Rudy Van Buren.
He grew up in the Netherlands,
next to a go-karting track.
At the age of eight,
he got given a birthday
present, a go-cart.
He was fast.
He was so fast, that in 2003,
Rudy won the Dutch national championships.
He had dreams and aspirations
of becoming a professional
Formula 1 driver.
Then at 16,
like so many people that are trying
to make that next step in the sport,
it just became too expensive.
And that dream for Rudy was over.
I'm going to come back to Rudy later.
Times change, and so does technology.
Dreams are being fulfilled
in a world of online gaming,
especially in this class of competition
called esports.
Esports, at its simplest,
is digital competition
where you can get real-world
and virtual prizes, fame and glory.
There will always be spectators,
in filling stadiums with spectators,
athletes, fans.
But now there are arenas
filled with die-hard fans
with gaming rigs
and a new class of elite competitor.
Most importantly, it's accessible.
Any one of us with a PlayStation, an Xbox,
a PC with a 100-dollar steering wheel
can go and get involved
in the thrill of competition.
More importantly, you can go
and connect with people
and share an online experience.
There are so many
different types of games.
Battle games, strategy games,
football games -- soccer --
or racing games.
The reason why I like racing
so much, it's unique.
It is the only digital sport
that represents the real world so much.
It is almost an exact twin
of the physical world.
As part of my day job,
I work with organizations
around the world.
I work for a software company
specialized in data.
My favorite organization I work with
at the moment is McLaren Racing.
McLaren, founded in 1963
by the New Zealander Bruce McLaren.
They’ve got an IndyCar team,
they have an extreme e-team.
They have my personal favorite,
the Formula 1 team.
Just look at that livery over there,
I think it's incredible.
But Bruce was an innovator.
In 1963, Bruce would have never imagined
that there would be
a professional gaming team,
the McLaren Shadow esports team,
That's their car.
These two cars are almost
indistinguishable from each other.
They're mirroring each other
in the physical
and the digital world of sports.
I spent time with Lando,
one of those drivers,
talking about gaming.
Lando is saying that the game,
not the state-of-the-art simulators
that the McLaren have,
the game,
is so realistic that he can tell
if a bump in the road is out of place.
The only thing that he feels
is missing is the wind.
Lando is one of these digital natives,
a new class of gamer,
where he drives in both the physical
world and the digital world
in that shared community.
The difference in Formula 1
between coming first and second
is a fraction of a second.
When you have elite people,
those 20 people in that car,
the only way they can go
and get better is by data.
It's the only way
they can differentiate themselves,
using data to improve.
This is exactly the same as esports.
There are team managers,
there are coaches, even psychologists,
but most importantly, data analysts.
In the racing game, the PC game,
they hit out around 300
different data points in real time
for you to analyze
and improve what you do.
Not real F1.
This is the game.
Things like tire temperature,
brakes, acceleration,
it's absolutely incredible.
It's also incredibly realistic.
Look at this.
Sometimes you can look at this and think
that could be real life.
It's an immersive experience.
When you're going down
that, kind of the back straight,
you're traveling about
293 feet per second.
The difference between making that corner
and dropping back
and not being in the lead
is a mere fraction of a second.
You want to know: Are your tires
at the right temperature?
You want to be able to know:
Are you hitting the brakes
at the right moment,
turning at that right moment?
They're using data
to improve again and again.
Here's Lando playing.
Lando would be playing
again over lockdown.
There was no Formula 1.
Lando ended up gaming.
The most empowering part about this,
it wasn't just he was using this
to practice his skill.
It was he was connecting
with an online community,
an absolutely unprecedented access
to Lando, the sports person.
Something you don't normally get.
Over lockdown, there was no sport.
Journalists started writing
about esports.
Mainstream broadcasters started
broadcasting esports on primary channels.
We started looking at esports
in the millions.
It was sport.
It was the only sport.
People under 20
are much more likely to start
to watch esports or watch esports,
than go and have a look
at traditional sports.
The Commonwealth Games this summer
is going to have esports
alongside traditional sports.
The Asian Games later this year
are going to have it as a medal event
alongside traditional sports.
The gaming industry is three times
bigger than the music industry.
It's going to double by 2025.
The most important part about it
is it's redefining our notion
of what is sports and competition
and how we get into
that accessible world of fun,
of connecting with people
and enjoying ourselves.
Now, I mentioned Rudy earlier.
For Rudy, his dream hit a wall.
He started gaming.
He really enjoyed it.
Then when he was 25, he saw a competition:
World's Fastest Gamer.
30,000 people entered this.
Rudy won.
Rudy got a professional contract
with the McLaren simulator team.
This led on to Rudy getting
a contract for Huber racing
in the Porsche Carrera Cup Germany
and the Super GT Cup.
Rudy is winning some of the most difficult
competitions in the world.
Just like he did in the virtual world.
Play gives us new possibilities.
The technology is closing the gap
between our aspirations
and our access to that opportunity.
It's closing down barriers,
geographic barriers, social barriers,
economic barriers.
It enabled Rudy to go and live his dream.
We all have dreams
and this is allowing us
to go and fulfill our dreams.
A new generation of people
is starting to understand
what it really means to go and live
in a world augmented by technology.
The relevance of it, the context of it,
what it actually means to go
and connect with people
and technology being part of everything.
They are able to go and reimagine
the world around them.
They’re more data literate than ever.
They're ready to go and create
that next wave of innovation.
This really is the new era for play.
And it's open to everyone.
Thank you.
(Applause)